the nrcc right now is running ads in
potential swing districts on
spending Democrats maxed out our
nation's credit card with Reckless
spending jacking up inflation to
Historic highs now they refuse to solve
the spending crisis they created voting
against a common sense plan to tackle
the government spending problem cut red
tape and curb our dependence on China
our economy hangs in the balance seven
million people could lose their jobs
extreme Democrats are addicted to
spending your money and you are paying
the price National Republican
Congressional committee is responsible
for the content of this advertising does
this work on anybody anymore I'm I'm not
knocking the ad or I'm not knocking
talking about spending okay maybe in
these swing districts right now during
the debt limit fight maybe it plays to
to run these TV ads I'm I'm not saying
don't run the ad I'm not saying you
should only run on the social issues but
does this work this doesn't work on me